saludar desde el balcón del palacio de
buckingham a los congregados en las
celebraciones de jubileo es una
tradición windsor que pasa de generación
en generación la lista de los elegidos
revela las relaciones de jerarquía así
como los escándalos o las tensiones
internas de la familia real británica
la decisión de contar solamente con los
miembros en activo de la familia real en
el balcón fue una lección muy prudente
porque evita situaciones incómodas si la
gente mira la dinámica familiar para ver
si hay tensiones y habría generado mucha
indignación pienso la presencia del
príncipe andrew sobre el balcón
la reina apartó al príncipe andrew de
sus funciones oficiales en 2019 tras las
revelaciones en la prensa sobre su
amistad con el estadounidense jeffrey
epstein acusado de múltiples casos de
violaciones contra mujeres y menores en
febrero de este 2002 el tercer hijo de
la reina también pagó varios millones de
dólares a la mujer que lo acusó de
agresión sexual ante un tribunal en eeuu
para cerrar el caso aunque niega las
acusaciones
el príncipe harry y la duquesa de esas
ex renunciaron a sus obligaciones reales
en 2020 ante la presión mediática así
que la pareja no estará sobre el balcón
pero participará en la conmemoración de
los 70 años de reinado de isabel segunda
del
palacio ha indicado claramente con harry
en megan continúan siendo miembros muy
queridos de la familia y que estarán ahí
ellos aseguraron que tenían muchas ganas
de festejar con la reina pienso que
aunque no estén sobre el balcón su sola
presencia que estén entre la familia de
nuevo y particularmente para el jubileo
de la reina demuestra que siguen en el
barco
sin duda la ausencia más dolorosa para
la monarca será la de su difunto esposo
el príncipe felipe que la acompañó
durante siete décadas de reinado